Hi, this is Edip Yuksel, 19.org.
I have some documents and some video recordings of Dr. Rashad Khalifa.
Uh, they have been with me for about 30 years, some of them 26 years after his assassination.
Now, you will be listening to his perhaps first announcement of 19, his discovery of Code 19 in 1974.
This video cassette on it with his own handwriting, it is written Radio Tripoli, Libya, 1974.
Year 1974 is written on it.
It is exactly the year of the discovery of Code 19, uh, which was secret in chapter named secret, The Hidden One.
Al-Muddathir means the secret chapter 74.
19 was hidden in chapter 74 for 19 times 74 lunar years after the revelation of the Quran.
And it was discovered in 1974 by Rashad Khalifa, whose name Rashad, the the all the derivatives of Rashad is mentioned in the Quran is exactly 19 times.
code of the Quran, which was also discovered in some old original portion of the Old Testament by Rabbi Judah in 11th century.
Okay, I want to leave you with this Rashad Khalifa's things.
Again, Rashad Khalifa discovered this 19 in 1974.
1974 lunar years after revelation of the Quran in year 1974, which is the numerical value of 19 letters of the first statement of this chapter.
يَا أَيُّهَا الْمُدَّثِّرُ قُمْ فَأَنذِرْ [Quran 74:1-2]
Oh, the hidden one, come out and warn.
It has 19 letters and the numerical value of these letters, which was used during time of Muhammad until two centuries after Muhammad, the geometrical values were used for numbers.
It is exactly 1974.
Okay, enjoy.
Okay, let's push.
In the beginning, there is recitation of the Quran and some music.
Maybe one or two minutes.
No, maybe one minute.
This is again Radio Tripoli, year 1974.
Dr. Rashad Khalifa is
القرآن الكريم والحديث من الجمهوريه العربيه الليبيه
declaring Code 19, his discovery in 1974.
The biggest historical event, I believe, in the
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
regarding philosophy and theology.
صدق الله العظيم
The greatest evidence belongs to God.
God has the greatest evidence, truth, and he guides.
And he is the one who guides.
He recited a verse.
Again, this is an old cassette, audio cassette.
Rashad's handwriting on it, written 1974 in Arabic, Radio Tripoli, Libya.
الاعجاز القراني
Al-I'jaz al-Qur'ani means the Quranic miracle.
برنامج من اذاعه القران الكريم والحديث
بالجمهوريه العربيه الليبيه
يعده ويقدمه
الدكتور رشاد خليفه
Rashad was Sunni that time.
Within few years, he rejects Hadith and Sunnah and in 1980, he published a book.
الحمد لله رب العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على خاتم النبيين سيدنا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
Later he did not, he rejected this.
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
من دراستنا لمعجزه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم في الحلقه السابقه
علمنا ان قارئ القران الكريم قبل ان يخطو خطوه واحده من خطوات رحلته تجاه رساله الله
تقابله معجزه باهره تحمل في طياتها الدليل المادي الملموس
ان هذا القران لا يمكن ان يكون من صنع البشر
وانه بحق رساله خالقه اليه ووسيله خلاصه وطريق سعادته في الدنيا والاخره
هذه المعجزه الواجده في بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
هي ان هذه الايه الاولى في القران الكريم تتركب من 19 حرفا
وكل كلمه من كلمات هذه الايه تتكرر في المصحف الشريف كله عددا من المرات
هو دائما من مقررات العدد 19
فكلمه اسم تتكرر في القران العظيم 19 مره
ولفظ الجلاله الله يتكرر 2698
والرقم 19 مكررا 142 مره
وكلمه الرحمن تتكرر في القران الكريم 57 مره
57 times
اي الرقم 19 مكررا ثلاث مرات
وكلمه الرحيم تتكرر 114 مره اي 19 مكرره ست مرات
وبدراسه جميع الاحتمالات الممكن استنتاجها من هذه الحقائق الاعجازيه القرانيه
خلصنا الى ان الاحتمال الوحيد الذي يمكن ان يقبله اي شخص عاقل
هو ان الله سبحانه وتعالى هو بحق منزل القران بما فيه من تصميم واحكام
وتطابق طاقات الانس والجن
فنحن عندما نتفكر في هذه الحقائق نجد ان كلمات القران الكريم
قد وضعت طبقا لتصميم حسابي وان القران كتاب احكمت اياته
ثم فصلت من لدن حكيم خبير
احكمت اياته اي وضعت باحكام وتدقيق وتصنيف
فنحن عندما نقول قل هو الله احد
نعلم الان ان كلمه الله هنا معدوده ومحسوبه اي موضوعه باحكام
فكلمه الله هنا واحده من 2698 المذكوره في القران كله
وهو كما ذكرت من مقررات الرقم 19 عدد حروف البسمله
وعندما نقول الله الصمد كلمه الله هنا ايضا معدوده ومحسوبه
كما اننا اذا نظرنا الى اخر ايه نزلت وهي باتفاق غالبيه الفقهاء
واتقوا يوما ترجعون فيه الى الله ثم توفى كل نفس ما كسبت وهم لا يظلمون
كلمه الله في هذه الايه اتمت العدد الذي شاءه الله سبحانه وتعالى
طبقا لاحكامه وتصميمه بحيث كانت كلمه الله في هذه الايه الاخيره
متممه للعدد 2698
واذا نظرنا الى كلمه الرحيم التي تتكرر في القران الكريم 114 مره
عدد سور القران الكريم واحد مقررات الرقم 19
يتبين لنا وجه جديد من اوجه الاعجاز وهو وجه الحفاظ على القران الكريم
وحمايته التامه من اي تحريف
ويكمن الاعجاز هنا في ان الذين نقلوا الينا هذا الكتاب الضخم
لم يكونوا اناسا طالعين في علوم المكتبات والتوثيق
ولم يكونوا من خبراء البحث العلمي بل كانوا من بدو الصحراء
الذين انقطعت صلتهم بالحضارات والعلوم
ولكي نستوضح هذا الوجه من وجوه الاعجاز فلننظر الى الايه 218 من سوره البقره
هذه الايه تقول
إِنَّ الَّذِينَ آمَنُوا وَالَّذِينَ هَاجَرُوا وَجَاهَدُوا فِي سَبِيلِ اللَّهِ أُولَٰئِكَ يَرْجُونَ رَحْمَتَ اللَّهِ ۚ وَاللَّهُ غَفُورٌ رَّحِيمٌ [Quran 2:218]
كلمه رحيم هنا واحده من 114 التي وضعت باحكام الهي
شانها في ذلك كما سنرى ان شاء الله شان كل كلمه بل كل حرف من حروف القران العظيم
ثم دعنا ننظر بعد ذلك الى الايه 225 من نفس السوره
هذه تقول
لَا يُؤَاخِذُكُمُ اللَّهُ بِاللَّغْوِ فِي أَيْمَانِكُمْ وَلَٰكِن يُؤَاخِذُكُم بِمَا كَسَبَتْ قُلُوبُكُمْ ۗ وَاللَّهُ غَفُورٌ حَلِيمٌ [Quran 2:225]
نعلم الان من معجزه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم ان كلمه حليم في هذه الايه
لم توضع صدفه او اعتباطا او عشوائيه
ونرى كيف ان بدو الصحراء الذين عاشوا في القرن السابع الميلادي
قد نقلوا الينا كتاب الله بامانه يعجز عنها علماء القرن العشرين
فمن السهل ان يخلط الانسان بين غفور رحيم وغفور حليم
خاصه وان هذه كلها اسماء الله الحسنى
ولكن الضمان الالهي
إِنَّا نَحْنُ نَزَّلْنَا الذِّكْرَ وَإِنَّا لَهُ لَحَافِظُونَ [Quran 15:9]
تكفل بالمحافظه على كل حرف في رساله الله الختاميه حتى تبقى معجزه ابديه
لا حاجه بعدها الى اضافات او تعديلات
وبين ايدينا من خلال هذه الحقائق الحسابيه الدليل المادي الملموس
ان القران الكريم قد وصل الينا محكما كاملا
وسنرى في الحلقات التاليه ان شاء الله ان القران الكريم
ليس فقط محكم الكلمات بل ان الحروف الابجديه نزلت باحكام دقيق
وتصميم حسابي معجز
ما هو دليلنا ان معجزه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم لها علاقه بكون القران الكريم من صنع الله عز وجل
وانه لا يمكن ان يكون من صنع البشر
ان الاجابه على هذا السؤال الهام تقع في سوره المدثر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ذَرْنِي وَمَنْ خَلَقْتُ وَحِيدًا [Quran 74:11]
وَجَعَلْتُ لَهُ مَالًا مَّمْدُودًا [Quran 74:12]
وَبَنِينَ شُهُودًا [Quran 74:13]
وَمَهَّدتُّ لَهُ تَمْهِيدًا [Quran 74:14]
ثُمَّ يَطْمَعُ أَنْ أَزِيدَ [Quran 74:15]
كَلَّا ۖ إِنَّهُ كَانَ لِآيَاتِنَا عَنِيدًا [Quran 74:16]
سَأُرْهِقُهُ صَعُودًا [Quran 74:17]
إِنَّهُ فَكَّرَ وَقَدَّرَ [Quran 74:18]
فَقُتِلَ كَيْفَ قَدَّرَ [Quran 74:19]
ثُمَّ قُتِلَ كَيْفَ قَدَّرَ [Quran 74:20]
ثُمَّ نَظَرَ [Quran 74:21]
ثُمَّ عَبَسَ وَبَسَرَ [Quran 74:22]
ثُمَّ أَدْبَرَ وَاسْتَكْبَرَ [Quran 74:23]
فَقَالَ إِنْ هَٰذَا إِلَّا سِحْرٌ يُؤْثَرُ [Quran 74:24]
إِنْ هَٰذَا إِلَّا قَوْلُ الْبَشَرِ [Quran 74:25]
سَأُصْلِيهِ سَقَرَ [Quran 74:26]
وَمَا أَدْرَاكَ مَا سَقَرُ [Quran 74:27]
لَا تُبْقِي وَلَا تَذَرُ [Quran 74:28]
لَوَّاحَةٌ لِّلْبَشَرِ [Quran 74:29]
عَلَيْهَا تِسْعَةَ عَشَرَ [Quran 74:30]
صدق الله العظيم
فنحن نرى من هذه الايات الكريمه ان الانسان الذي يقرر ان القران الكريم من قول البشر
سيسلط الله عليه 19
وفي ضوء ما نعلمه اليوم من معجزه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
فان هذه ال 19 هي حروف الايه الاولى في القران الكريم وهي بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والتي تحمل في طياتها الدليل الدامغ على ان القران الكريم لا يمكن ان يكون من قول البشر
ويتحتم ان ننوه هنا بالتفسيرات القديمه التي قالت ان ال 19 هنا ملائكه يحرسون النار
وبني هذا التفسير على اساس الايه التاليه لايه عليها 19
حيث تقول
وَمَا جَعَلْنَا أَصْحَابَ النَّارِ إِلَّا مَلَائِكَةً ۙ وَمَا جَعَلْنَا عِدَّتَهُمْ إِلَّا فِتْنَةً لِّلَّذِينَ كَفَرُوا لِيَسْتَيْقِنَ الَّذِينَ أُوتُوا الْكِتَابَ وَيَزْدَادَ الَّذِينَ آمَنُوا إِيمَانًا ۙ وَلَا يَرْتَابَ الَّذِينَ أُوتُوا الْكِتَابَ وَالْمُؤْمِنُونَ ۙ وَلِيَقُولَ الَّذِينَ فِي قُلُوبِهِم مَّرَضٌ وَالْكَافِرُونَ مَاذَا أَرَادَ اللَّهُ بِهَٰذَا مَثَلًا ۚ كَذَٰلِكَ يُضِلُّ اللَّهُ مَن يَشَاءُ وَيَهْدِي مَن يَشَاءُ ۚ وَمَا يَعْلَمُ جُنُودَ رَبِّكَ إِلَّا هُوَ ۚ وَمَا هِيَ إِلَّا ذِكْرَىٰ لِلْبَشَرِ [Quran 74:31]
صدق الله العظيم
تبدا الايه بالقول وما جعلنا اصحاب النار الا ملائكه
وهو تعبير يوحي بان عليها 19 ربما تعني ان حراس النار هم 19 من الملائكه
وكان هذا هو مصدر التفسير القديم الذي كان مناسبا للاجيال السابقه والتي لم يشاء الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان يطلعهم على معجزه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الا ان بدايه الايه وما جعلنا اصحاب النار الا ملائكه لا تحمل الاختبار
او الالتزام بان ال 19 هم حراس النار
وباستمرارنا في تلاوه الايه نجد انها تقول
وما جعلنا عدتهم الا اي ما جعلنا هذا العدد 19
وما اخترناه الا للاسباب التاليه
اولا فتنه للذين كفروا اي ازعاجا واخلاقا للذين كفروا
واثباتا وتركيزا لكفرهم
ثانيا ليستيقن الذين اوتوا الكتاب
فهناك من اهل الكتاب من يتساءل هل القران صحيح منزل من عند الله
فالعدد 19 هنا جاء بما فيه من معاني ليستيقن الذين اوتوا الكتاب
ليعلموا ويتاكدوا ويستيقنوا ان هذا القران الكريم
جاء بالفعل من عند ربنا وربهم من عند الله الواحد القهار
ثالثا ويزداد الذين امنوا ايمانا اي اننا نحن المؤمنون
بان هذا القران هو كتاب من عند الله يزداد ايماننا عن طريق ال 19
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
عليها 19
وما جعلنا اصحاب النار الا ملائكه وما جعلنا عدتهم الا فتنه للذين كفروا
ليستيقن الذين اوتوا الكتاب ويزداد الذين امنوا ايمانا
ويحضرني هنا ما يساله بعض الناس هل نحن في حاجه الى هذه البراهين والدلائل
وسنجيب ان شاء الله على هذا السؤال ونستكمل هذه الحلقه
في المره القادمه ان شاء الله والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
I'm not sure after this one whether we have more recording because first time I'm listening.
I don't want to risk the cassette since it is an old one.
Let me check.
I'm going to pause here.
الاعجاز القراني
اذاعه القران الكريم والحديث من الجمهوريه العربيه الليبيه
اخوه الايمان في ختام فتره ارسال اذاعه القران الكريم والحديث
نستمع خاشعين الى ما يتيسر من سوره الاعراف من تسجيلات المرحوم
الشيخ كامل يوسف البهتيمي
There is Quranic recitation following up.
I will stop recording after few verses.
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
فلو شاء لهداكم اجمعين
صدق الله العظيم
I really don't know whether there is more coming from Rashad Khalifa.
I'm waiting like you do.
First time I'm listening after 26 years from my having this cassette since 1974.
الاعجاز القراني
I hope this is the second session of Dr. Rashad Khalifa's announcement of Code 19, his discovery.
In previous section, he summarized about the frequency of the words in Basmalah.
الاعجاز القراني برنامج من اذاعه القران الكريم والحديث بالجمهوريه العربيه الليبيه
يعده ويقدمه الدكتور رشاد خليفه
Oh, hopefully this is the second session.
Unfortunately, they add Hadith, the satanic teachings to the Quran.
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على خاتم النبيين سيدنا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
As you hear Dr. Khalifa that time, he was still influenced by Sunni teaching.
They distort the verses, uh,
إِنَّ اللَّهَ وَمَلَائِكَتَهُ يُصَلُّونَ عَلَى النَّبِيِّ [Quran 33:56]
that verse, they distort the meaning of salla.
They say you must say, qul, and then some words.
In fact, it is about supporting, uh, prophet, the leader while he was alive.
God and his angels support the prophet.
Oh, believer, you support him too.
But similar two verses also there is that tells Muhammad,
خُذْ مِنْ أَمْوَالِهِمْ صَدَقَةً تُطَهِّرُهُمْ وَتُزَكِّيهِم بِهَا وَصَلِّ عَلَيْهِمْ ۖ إِنَّ صَلَاتَكَ سَكَنٌ لَّهُمْ [Quran 9:103]
tells Muhammad to salli 'ala them.
I use the same word so that you hear it, to support them.
Therefore, the word salli 'ala is not something to be uttered but to be done, not only to Muhammad, also Muhammad had to do to believers around, to believers I say, well, to those who who trust in God or the peacemakers around him.
And also we see another verse, there are three verses about salli 'ala,
هُوَ الَّذِي يُصَلِّي عَلَيْكُمْ وَمَلَائِكَتُهُ لِيُخْرِجَكُم مِّنَ الظُّلُمَاتِ إِلَى النُّورِ [Quran 33:43]
God and his angels, the controllers, um, supports you.
Uh, supports you to to basically take you out of darkness to enlighten you.
And again, we see it that salli 'ala is not exclusive for Muhammad, is also for all those who are righteous, who are peacemakers, who are monotheist.
And God and his angels, they do salat to them too.
Therefore, uh, the Sunni Shiite clergyman, later they distorted the meaning of salli 'ala as an exclusive prayer or praise for Muhammad.
Uh, I wanted to pull your attention to this one.
Rashad Khalifa in his landmark book, uh, landmark book Quran, Hadith and Islam, he exposes this distortion very well.
And that book, in fact, when I read it after several round of debate with him through snail mail, while I was in Turkey in 1986, um, in 1st July, I was able to receive from him.
He sent me the book after some heated debate.
I was defending Hadith.
I was sending him Hadith and he was sending me one verse with swallowing all the Hadith, all the snakes, like Moses' staff.
Each time he was responding with verses, I would respond with fabricated Hadith.
Hadith and yuftara.
And then I got confused and I couldn't leave Hadith altogether because, uh, I was my father was the very well-known, very influential Sunni scholar.
I was very heavily poisoned.
My understanding of verses was very different.
I thought obeying God and messenger, messenger means Bukhari's fabrications.
And then he asked me whether I had his book Quran, Hadith and Islam.
I said no.
I said, I said, I wrote, that time I was communicating through mail.
And then he sent me Quran, Hadith and Islam.
I read it in a couple of hours.
It is very easy read book and, oh my God, it was unbelievable.
It changed my life and that night was the night of power, Laylatul Qadr, my Laylatul Qadr.
That time the Quran revealed to me.
Initially that the Quran was ambiguous, that I couldn't understand, that I thought it needs volumes, volumes of contradictory Hadith books.
Again, undefined volumes.
There are six volumes and they have also different classification of Hadith.
And besides that, there are other Hadith and also the teachings of sectarian fatwas and all those books, really you don't know what is what.
Ask the followers of Hadith and Sunnah, how many really authentic Hadith you have?
They will never be able to come up with the Hadith.
They, they have 31 classification, 31 classification of Hadith from Mawdu to Mutawatir.
Even their top, supposedly the most authentic Mutawatir Hadith, if you ask them their number, they will not come into an agreement regarding even their Mutawatir Hadith, the most authentic Hadith.
Ironically, the most authentic Hadith, according to them is the Hadith about not writing anything besides the Quran from Muhammad.
لا تكتبوا عني شيئا سوى القران فمن يكتب فليمحوه
there is that Hadith.
And this is supposedly a Mutawatir means it is narrated by very multiple chains, so many chains that it is impossible to doubt its authenticity.
But this very Mutawatir Hadith, according to their own claim, is trashed by an Ahad, one single Hadith made up later and they trash this Hadith.
So contradictory.
Anyway, I put a long parenthesis about Rashad's utterance, the Mushriks, Sunni Mushriks distortion about Muhammad.
They praise God, they cannot praise God alone.
They always need an urge to add Muhammad's name.
Even in Azan, they'd added,
وَأَنَّ الْمَسَاجِدَ لِلَّهِ فَلَا تَدْعُوا مَعَ اللَّهِ أَحَدًا [Quran 72:18]
Uh, the Masajid belongs to God alone, the temples, do not call anyone besides God.
But they add Muhammad's name and also La ilaha illallah throughout the Quran is only God mentioned when God's oneness is emphasized, no other name is juxtaposed, but they add Muhammad's name to it.
They violate, uh, 39:45, chapter 49, verse 45 and also 3:18, chapter 3, verse 18.
It is about Shahadat approved by God and angels and those who are endowed with knowledge.
And also their Shahada very interestingly is exposed as the Shahada of hypocrites in chapter 63, verse 1.
And also the archaeological evidence, the earliest coins, um, gold coins, gold and silver coins of Umayyad times, initially, you don't see Muhammad's name on it, only La ilaha illallah or Allahu Ahad, Allahu Samad or La ilaha illallah wahdahu la sharika lah.
And later generation, you see Muhammad's name add to the margin in circle through copy and paste, cut, copy and paste.
From the last verse of chapter Fatiha.
And then they later they put in the backside in the middle and then only in fourth stage, each takes about 10, 15, 20 years.
And then in last stage of coins, finally, the Satan is able through make them get familiar with Muhammad's name and then in the end put next to God in the middle.
Okay, let's listen.
ايها الاخوه والاخوات السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
حدثتكم في الحلقه السابقه عن علاقه معجزه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم بالايه القرانيه
عليها 19 وهي الايه رقم 30 من سوره المدثر
وراينا في ضوء هذه المعجزه القرانيه ان ال 19 المذكورين في هذه الايه
هم على اغلب الظن ال 19 حرفا الذين تتكون منهم الايه الاولى في القران
وهي البسمله وان التفسير القديم بان ال 19 هم حراس النار
قد لا يكون تفسيرا صحيحا اذ ان الايه التاليه رقم 31 من سوره المدثر تقول
وما جعلنا عدتهم الا فتنه للذين كفروا ليستيقن الذين اوتوا الكتاب
ووقفنا في الحلقه السابقه عند السبب الثالث الذي من اجله اختار الله سبحانه وتعالى
العدد 19 مسلطا اياه على كل من يقول بان القران من قول البشر
هذا السبب الثالث كما تبين الايه هو
ويزداد الذين امنوا ايمانا
وهنا طرحت السؤال الذي يساله بعض الناس وهو
هل نحن في حاجه الى كل هذه البراهين والدلائل على اعجاز القران
اننا نؤمن ونصدق ان القران الكريم هو بحق من قول الله سبحانه وتعالى
لماذا تستخدمون الالات الحاسبه الالكترونيه او العقول الالكترونيه للبحث عن الاعجاز القراني
ونحن نرى الاجابه على هذه الاسئله كلها في الايه 31 من سوره المدثر
وما جعلنا عدتهم اي العدد 19 المذكور في الايه السابقه
وما جعلنا عدتهم الا فتنه للذين كفروا ليستيقن الذين اوتوا الكتاب
ويزداد الذين امنوا ايمانا
ولقد كان لنا اسوه حسنه في سيدنا الخليل ابراهيم عليه السلام
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
واذ قال ابراهيم رب ارني كيف تحيي الموتى
قال اولم تؤمن قال بلى ولكن ليطمئن قلبي
اين نحن من ابي الانبياء سيدنا ابراهيم ها هو يسال الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان يريه كيف يحيي الموتى ليطمئن قلبه ليزداد ايمانه
ولم يغضب الله سبحانه وتعالى من هذا الطلب ولم يعلق رسوله ابراهيم عليه السلام بل قال له
خذ اربعه من الطير فصرهن اليك ثم اجعل على كل جبل منهن جزءا
ثم ادعهن ياتينك سعيا واعلم ان الله عزيز حكيم
فاذا كانت هذه حال سيدنا ابراهيم عليه السلام الذي جعله الله للناس اماما
فما احوجنا نحن الى ان نتدبر القران وان نبحث عما فيه من معجزات باهرات
ليزداد الذين امنوا ايمانا كما تقول هذه الايه الكريمه من سوره المدثر
السبب الرابع الذي من اجله اختار الله سبحانه وتعالى الرقم 19
ليكون حجه على الذين يقولون بان القران من قول البشر
هذا السبب الرابع كما تعلمنا الايه
ولا يرتاب الذين اوتوا الكتاب والمؤمنون
اي لازاله الريبه والشكوك الذي قد تراود اهل الكتاب والمؤمنين
الحجه الالهيه الدامغه ان شاء الله
النظريه الاولى في تفسير او شرح لدلاله الحروف النورانيه
واعتبرت هذه المحاوله محاوله دراسه العلاقه بين الحروف النورانيه
واسماء الله الحسنى المذكوره في السور في فواتح السور محاوله فاشله
لا تستطيع ان تفسر لنا دلالات ومعاني الحروف النورانيه
وانتقلت الدراسه بعد ذلك الى العلاقه بين حروف النورانيه واسماء الرسل والانبياء المذكورين في السور التي افتتحوا بهذه الحروف
يعني مثلا في سوره مريم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
كاف ها يا عين صاد ذكر رحمه ربك عبده زكريا
هل الحرف الكاف في كاف ها يا عين صاد يرمز الى سيدنا زكريا عليه السلام
وكان مصير هذه المحاوله الفشل كما فشلت المحاوله السابقه لها
وهكذا استمرت محاولات فهم دلالات الحروف النورانيه وتكرر الفشل
واخيرا وفقني الله سبحانه وتعالى الى دراسه العلاقه بين الحروف النورانيه
ونظام توزيع هذه الحروف في جميع سور القران الكريم
واثبت ان القران الكريم نزل من عند الخالق عز وجل الى الحبيب المصطفى صلى الله عليه وسلم
عن طريق الروح الامين جبريل عليه السلام
النظريه الثامنه
ثامنا ربط ابن عباس رضي الله عنهما بين الحروف الف لام راء
والحرفان ح م والحرف نون وخرج من ذلك بالاسم الرحمن
الرحمن
النظريه التاسعه والاخيره اقترح العالم الباكستاني الجليل عبد الله يوسف علي
ان هناك علاقه بين هذه الحروف وبين مخارجها
عند النطق
فمثلا الحروف الف لام ميم نجد فيها ان الحرف الف يخرج من عمق من الحلق
واللام مخرجها عند طرف اللسان والميم مخرجها عند الشفاه
وكما ذكرت من قبل فان جميع العلماء الاجلاء الذين قاموا بتقديم هذه النظريات والتفسيرات
حول دلاله او معاني الحروف النورانيه
قد اجمعوا على ان تفسيراتهم لا تتعدى كونها تخمينات واستنتاجات لا تستند الى دليل
ويجدر بي هنا ان اسجل نظره اهل التحقيق الى هذه الحروف النورانيه
متمثله فيما قاله الامام الجليل محي الدين بن عربي في كتابه
Muhyiddin ibn Arabi, he was an idol worshiper.
ولضيق الوقت فاني سابدا الحلقه القادمه باذن الله بما قاله الامام ابن عربي عن هذه الحروف النورانيه
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
صدق الله العظيم
الف لام
Okay.
I'm going to find out whether there is another continuation of this declaration, which is historical.
Okay, uh, see you later.
This fall, one of the universe's greatest mysteries will be revealed.
A scientific discovery that is epic in its importance, but underestimated to this day.
There is a highly complex mathematical code in the Quran, the ancient book that was written more than a thousand years ago.
The authenticity of which can be verified independently by anyone.
Asselbek Musin in the popular science film, an ordinary miracle.
What is Islam?
Um, what are the sources of Islam?
What are the sources of Islam?
What is Islam?
Burdasen, inshallah.
Nereye?
Gidiyorum.